yesterday we have been seeing lot of
small talks there's the handshake the
game Tire to talk here we go E4 E5 girl
old
Spanish Magnus adjusting plays A6 looks
like No Nonsense both sides playing
their main openings Bishop E7 Rook E1 or
D3 yeah Rook E1 dude as a classical guy
let's see if he goes C3 telling Magnus
please show me the Marshall now A4 B4
okay a very fashionable line very trendy
not sticking with his Rook B8 Bishop B7
lines which we both had the pleasure of
studying during the world championship
match but said he goes for B4 which has
always been the main line but Magnus
historically hasn't liked it that much
yeah and it's interesting that after A4
B4 D4 D6 after d takes E5 he captured
with the PA yeah normally people take
with a knight it's simpler but he's
trying to keep more pieces on the board
this some old line Bishop C5 H6 Queen E7
and so on I'm sure I'm sure we both
looked at it at some point in the 20110
but don't ask me for
details yeah it's one of those
mysterious uh positions I believe this
whole Knight V2 was brought in by Guk in
uh the candidates tournament in London
2013 I think that that's when it was
introduced and people took it very
seriously lot of high clevel high level
clashes there I never liked for black
just aesthetically because you have
these weaknesses on the queen side
that's why I always like this bishop B7
Rook B8 lines Magnus used to play but
here it's back to the roots I'm not sure
about the move order Queen E7 maybe loud
Bishop D5 memory SS there was some H6
Queen D6 setups
anyway some subtleties a little easier
to play for white Bishop D5 Knight B3 is
a typical idea but I'm not sure how much
it does here and they just develop
pieces Queen
to yeah now things have stabilized kind
of after the trade of light squ Bishops
black queen gets a very nice little
square on E6 on the other hand white
gets easy development we see Knight B3
Bishop E3 after the trade of Bishops
there will be a lovely C5 Square
potentially for White's queen or the
knight in an end game at the moment
Knight C5 probably will be met by Queen
C4 Queen C4 yeah black looks looks solid
enough barely some counter playay though
with Queen C4 to keep the balance if
white goes Queen C5 and then we can kick
it maybe some Knight
D7 yeah it's uh little bit too early
also somewh B8 yes exactly the typical
way in this type of structures if black
gets The Rook to B5 this will
beautifully guard the C5 pawn and Target
the A5
weakness then is fine yeah if you go
Rook D1 I go Queen C4 I don't see
anything special for it yeah no it's
actually maybe slightly more preferable
to play with black because with black
you don't you don't play for an
advantage you play just play natural
moves and if with natural moves you can
hope for something that's an ideal
scenario yeah he goes Queen E2 I like
that move stopping Queen C4 and hinting
at Knight
C5 and also stopping Rook B8 Rook B5 yes
very nice
move
db8 but that's not the dream of course
getting up the open file no Magnus goes
KN
H5 he's so in tune with the details of
the position here Queen E2 nice move but
it allows Knight H5 Knight F4 white
can't go G3 right now and Knight
C5 wow the English term
Intero Knight to F4 yeah Knight F4
Intero yeah Knight C6 Knight D2 is so
tricky it looks like black has a damage
Pawn structure but the A5 Pawn will be
we black will follow it up with Rook B8
Rook B5 yeah magnos doesn't love that
pawn structure and look more subtleties
King F1 he doesn't take the Knight but
black could go Knight G3 also Blake
breaking the white structure and he
does take stes some clever
stuff now black a little better no Rook
B8 Rook B5 yeah also up on one minute up
on the clock but I wanted to refer to
that incredible legendary Magnus Carson
leonado game when this A5 Pawn was
finally captured and it was actually a
mistake to capture that pawn so these
positions are very tricky but black can
put the hook on
D6 yeah Black's very solid King comes
Rook D6 and Rook B8 Rook B5 is always
lurking as a plan dude has to be careful
here this could be a vintage Magnus
Carson technical
performance I don't know if you saw that
game in the rapid where he played
against R Jaa and looked like he was
slightly worse all the time just quietly
exchanging the pieces and then he just
won easily I don't know how he does it
in these
positions that was the only game that I
missed from Magnus to be honest fair
enough fair enough I was impressed with
it was very quiet but somehow yeah he
always measures to grind something out
even from these slightly worse positions
but I'm not exactly happy with his
choice by taking on D1 wasn't Rook D6
much more interesting putting pressure
on dudas cloak and now things are bit
easier and dudah creates counter play he
just wants that A5 Pawn but dud goes for
G4 G5 yeah and also if Rook
B5 I know I was going to say Rook A1 but
actually it doesn't save the pawn yeah
it doesn't yeah so King E3 L B5 G5 takes
takes B3 Choice wow so he's implying
that against C3 wants to take with the
Knight and threat Knight C4 check going
after the B2
Pawn putting pressure
and no time for Duda he needs to speed
up play Rook one good
reaction Knight takes
A5 now I he out Knight C4 check oh
that's probably bad news Knight F3
Knight
C4 now King E2 just takes and Rook takes
B2 and black has a pass a pawn that
looks winning no this looks
winning Rook Rook B2 with with a damage
Pawn structure and some ordination white
king might come to se streets not easy
the
AO he brings the king he's classy
guy yeah King D6 strong move no he's
gonna
win yeah White's Knight is moving too
far away down to 4 seconds dude they
shaking his
head not happy with how this has
gone no not at all certainly
not magos go back with the King look
like Magnus went back didn't want King
C5 some I don't know Knight D5 Knight d8
Knight D5 Adventures okay but then D is
maybe back because he he gets play that
was strange by Magnus s pushing the a he
makes a million Knight moves do that
coordinate yeah what
still with 5 Seconds on the clock just
one mistake and it can cause the game
Magnus setting
uping yeah I thought he would start with
H5 but how does Magnus make
progress yeah that's uh that's the key
that's what yanish has in mind I just
going to sit and wait the black king is
kind of stuck or at least the pieces are
stuck because always you have to watch
out for a timely H5 break not obvious he
wants to go some positions changed some
Knight D3 Knight B4 Knight C6 white can
maybe go Knight
A5 yeah look at that Knight on C4 beauti
for blockade Knight
E5 it might be a
Fortress Yeah Carlson also not blitzing
out the moves he's looking for a
way one Knight B7 after the pawn Knight
B7 now Knight F3 then Knight takes C5
wins both pawns on the queen side dude
that's surviving
but still the G5 Pawn can also fall and
then this could be unpleasant about
Knight H for King east3 making sure that
the G5 Pawn stays
alive yeah Knight G2 Knight F4 Knight E6
we're still got to try with the King
comes to G4 and two
seconds enough enough Knight
B8 into the middle of nowhere but it's
got to get trapped Knight C5 yay Blended
the pawn cuz he couldn't go King G4
because of Knight
C5 yeah this is what I F like why do you
do this i' still be a draw yeah I think
it's still a draw
but more
well yeah this is very tough with so
little time on the
clock I think he will lose it Knight D7
Knight forever for some
Knight Knight double attack bring the
king yeah this is very
difficult yeah this
is this this is very
tough Knight D4 Carlson has all the time
in the world as long as he doesn't give
one of the pawns and only G5 Knight D3
not breaking through just yet yeah not
yet but uh but with only 4 seconds on
the clock this is so tough to
defend C shuffling but not making
progress yeah now white has improved his
position
yes if black ever forces the issue pawns
might get
exchanged King back to
F3 try King H4 to go G5 G4 but Knight D7
bothers him Knight
F7 protecting the pawn Knight F6 to go
Knight H6 Knight D7 back attacking the
pawn but there is this G5 G4 Knight Tak
G4 Knight G5 trick be careful actually
now G5 King F3 G4
yeah yes it's
lost and then black made progress now
the king can come to F4 this looks
winning
though D shaking his
head has to give up the E Pawn yeah this
is winning yeah now with two pawns up
this is easy winning Agnes finding a way
do the
resigns wow so Magnus has done
it